do you want to tell us what's going on
in the uk i don't know this is a pretty
crazy story this is a real story and a
crazy story
this is not this this is this i think
this is going to offend some people well
it's going to offend some people but i
think
i don't think we are going to offend
people i think they're going to be
shocked and offended finding out do you
want to pull up the story guy if you
have it on the internet
if you don't have it tom why don't you
just tell us what's going on so
there's a lot of cultures that are in
london there's been a lot of immigration
it's a very diverse city a lot of people
there
and there's a thriving muslim community
and in muslim culture it's very
important
that you marry a muslim woman
preferably not someone that's converted
proverb preferably from a family of
origination
and that she be a virgin and
they live in london and london is a
diverse
and it's seen as a western city yeah and
so
you have a lot of muslim families that
are saying hey this is a diverse western
city how do we know that that muslim
woman you want to marry coming from a
good muslim family how do we know she's
a virgin
you know this is important to us this is
you you have to make your your faith
vows and everything is really important
and so there's organization there
that is offering virginity tests
and controversial virginity tests sold
by uk
and here it is bbc news and everything
and women are being offered
controversial virginity tests at british
medical clinics as
an investor investigation on my bbc
newsbeat and hunter woman has found
the intrusive tests are considered
violation of human rights by the world
health organization united nations which
one to
see them banned critics say that they
are unscientific cannot be proven
whether someone is a virgin and cannot
can be a form of abuse the tests involve
a vaginal examination to check if human
hymen is intact the bbc investigation
found a member of private clinics and
advertising virginity repair which when
contacted then also offered the
so-called virginity test for between 100
wait virginity repair
this kind of this kind of takes me back
to what again
i was about to say t.i and his pictures
down there when t.i had his daughter
and he says you know i have my daughter
tested every year to see if she's a
virgin or not do you remember that story
or no it's right there
yeah uh last year u.s rapper t.i
sparked outrage after revealing he takes
his daughter for a test every year to
check her hyman is still intact
all said they would carry out hyman
repair surgery which costs in the region
of 1500 to 3 000
pounds data from nhs includes show
69-heim and repair procedures have been
carried out what wait what
am i reading this correct is it saying
you pay 1500 to 3 000
pounds to to make it seem like the
person is a virgin
right so it this is akin to first of all
it's horrible
what if some yeah forget your faith
tradition
what if some poor muslim girl is
misdiagnosed by the doctor and she wants
to get married to this guy
now the family won't have her no she
meets a nice muslim guy they want to get
married they say well no no no we want
to make sure that she's been living in
london we're living in western society
we want to make sure that you haven't
done anything you know that's
in their culture yeah and then the
doctor tells
well no no no she's not that poor woman
is now ostracized in her culture
i know that because that's how it is in
iran just so you know i feel bad for
that girl
how was it yeah yeah oh i mean if uh so
you know culturally the husband and wife
would go in the room and the sheets
would come out and show
blood and hey this is that's that's a
ritual that's not that
you say you know she's a virgin and they
they're they're cheering for the blood
that's that's the sheets you show the
sheets with blood
is it's this this is on the wedding
night or this this is this is a ritual
that's something
on the wedding night or whatever i don't
know the details of what like what
timing of it at seven
some of these are like wedding weeks
right they're saying this is going on
anyway i had a very emotional abusive
relation my parents who wanted to have
an arranged marriage she says one day an
elderly
community saw me out of my friends and
said to my mom that one of the boys was
my boyfriend there was lots of rumors in
the community about it she was then
threatened with the virginity test by
her parents my parents and the family of
the man
they wanted me to marry said i had to do
virginity test to prove that i was still
a virgin so the marriage could go ahead
i was scared and didn't really
understand what it meant
i felt running away was my only option
so that's what i did
priya montoya manages the the helpline
for
karma nirvana we had received calls from
girls who are concerned about this it
might be
that they are worried their families
have found out perhaps they've been in a
relationship or they're not a virgin it
might be a family or pressure in them to
go through
listen by the way this sounds radical
it's very common where i came from
this sounds radical but it's very common
where i came from so
the question becomes if you're watching
this how how crazy is this
world health organization's saying is
saying is what this is absolutely
ludicrous what are your thoughts well i
mean
this look being from miami south beach
i'm used to this i mean we
i mean if you're a virgin uh this is
what we
you know this is how we do it at south
beach like there's virgins galore in
south beach all the uh the models down
there that's
we're looking for this is why nobody
gets married because there's no there's
no freaking virgins down there
uh there's a lot of weird stuff going on
here
i don't know we went there tom uh just a
lot of weird stuff going on here
i just i got so many questions here i
know that in the muslim religion and i'm
not
completing any issue i'm just this this
comes to mind
that when a suicide bomber you know they
blow themselves up why do they do it
because they're going to go to heaven
and they're going to get
72 virgins i've always had a question
about that so a lot of freaking virgins
so how long are you in heaven
eternity yeah okay let me let me get a
pencil calculator
eternity no 72. no
you're gonna run out of virgins i mean
there's a lot of versions out there i'm
just thinking trinity's a long time
maybe you cut a deal you get up there
every time they lose their virginity
they do that procedure
maybe they're doing something like that
well that's the other part see the other
part is
you know is there are
i think companies in here i think with
the who's point now that there's
companies in here
exploiting people like virginity repair
isn't that like
paying a bad mechanic to roll the
odometer back on your car
yes yes 20 years ago that was actually a
thing that you did yeah they don't want
low miles they want no miles
but but the point is here's even go go
forget about the ritual part i respect
rituals of families you know it's your
ritual it is what it is now
i don't have to follow the rituals that
you follow i'm just telling you but i
respect the fact that certain religions
have
certain religions you're jewish
christian christians some are atheists
some are
you know mormons jehovah there's a lot
of different rituals that's out there
and they're they're not the same
so to someone a jewish ritual maybe some
random stuff to do like are you kidding
me you really have to go yes you do
uh but then there is rituals that cause
people to be rebellious i mean you are
pretty much
forcing me to be rebellious here you
know they used to say
when when when middle eastern kids and
girls who were
suppressed in iran and armenia they come
to the states
and they gain their freedom game over
you can't tell me what to do i'm gonna
go
and have my fun daddy you don't like it
guess what
i'm gonna have five boyfriends that's
what i'm gonna be doing it's a form of a
rebelliousness right okay
um the catholic school girl thing you
told me what to do my whole life and
then you end up moving to south beach
and then you're the freaking oh
you meet adam and the next thing you
know things are changing it's changing
so
anyways i don't know how we went to the
story tom but i do think it's craziness
going on in uk that is the pressure of
what happens
when a community says yes yes yes yes
yes and then eventually like wait a
minute what the hell are we saying yes
to
that's what's happening uk right now
this this is brought in brought
brought on to them by the folks who
voted for their politicians
who eventually pushed the envelope to
this point where they're saying this is
what we're doing next and now they want
it to be reverted back
it's too late you already accepted it
momentum's on their side anyways okay
you you wrote this down right here and
that's exactly what i was thinking i
don't know how old his daughter is i'm
not speculating but
that's exactly she's like you're gonna
check me every year of my life for my
virginity
at some point she's been like dad like
i'm i'm freaking out over here so
yeah it's it's a it's a it's a little
too much when you do that so you know
how you're going to appointments i used
to always run into appointments and the
guy would
sit there and i'm in the middle of an
appointment we're making a sale and the
guy would have to pick up the call every
time his wife called
i'm like dude what the we're in the
middle of what we're not pat you don't
understand i have to pick up the call
what do you mean you have to pick up the
call i'm just telling you we have an
arrangement
what kind of an arrangement is this
whenever she calls have to pick up
every time every single time that's he
had to pick up
so freaking so he was hey i'm over here
hey patrick can you say hi to mary
i'm like hey hi hey hey mary
okay okay babe bye
i'm like what get a life bro so then
we'd go on another i have a friend like
yeah we'd be driving i was like okay bro
so we're going
to tell you okay stop wait hey
patrick can you say hi like what the
hell and then he finally told me he says
well
one time yeah she lost trust because she
saw something on my phone yeah i have to
do this for the rest of my life jesus
christ that you can't do that for for
long term you cannot do it it's not it's
not
a sustainable it's not a sustainable
model you're eventually gonna piss off
and the guy's gonna be like you know
what screw you i'm not picking up your
calls